bonjour fait de récupérer les clés du
service merci les clés du service c'est
le nom de l'entreprise créée en janvier
2018 par frédéric pellerin une société
de services à la personne
alors vous venez pour envoyer mon ordi
net ou alors on va faire d'abord dhien
et puis on fera dans la foulée le propre
petit problème des vielles plus qu'aux
ok ça marche on y va ce jour là michel a
besoin de frédéric notamment pour
intervenir sur la surchauffe de son
ordinateur
donc malgré des montages de
dépoussiérage il a continué à faire du
bruit
d'accord de l'assistance informatique du
ménage du bricolage ou encore du
jardinage différents services à domicile
proposé par frédéric dans différentes
communes autour des clayes-sous-bois ce
que j'ai fait dans un premier temps
c'est que je me suis fait connaître
auprès les associations dans les
associations principalement de seniors
au niveau de la ville des claies mais
pas que ce que je suis je suis rentré en
contact avec le ccrs donc de la ville
des clubs mais également de plaisir je
suis allé à villepreux pour me faire
connaître
alors monsieur pellerin a déjà été à une
personne très agréable à l'heure il est
patient je les utilise pour mes
déplacements je les utilise pour les
petits services comme l'ordinateur et
l'évier éventuellement si j'ai besoin
d'autres services je contacterai alors
20 à 49 ans frédéric a décidé de se
reconvertir
pendant près de vingt ans il a occupé un
poste de chargé de mission dans une
filiale informatique d'une banque un
métier complet des événements personnels
difficiles les raisons de son burnout un
état d'épuisement professionnel les
entreprises je pense que je suis pas le
seul mais on est bien souvent qu'un
numéro
dans ces fameux numéro où on tient pas
franchement pas pas toujours compte de
l'intérêt de la personne des envies de
la personne de ce que la personne peut
subir ce qu'elle peut vivre
aidé par sa femme et ses deux filles
frédérique a réussi à tourner la page
avec l'aide de la chambre de commerce de
l'industrie il crée son entreprise en
suivant sa vocation l'envi de se
remettre en question de se rendre utile
de se lever le matin et de deux
avec le smile et non comme une corvée y
est d'aller bosser deux voies la fin
vraiment le principe de se rendre utile
d'apporter quelque chose à autrui et
c'est vraiment ce que ce que j'ai envie
de faire et puis bah voila c'est de se
dire aujourd'hui tient comme je faire
par qui je vais être appelé
et puis puis c'est ce sont des petites
satisfaction de voir tout à l'heure on a
vu madame madame du monde voilà
l'apprécier apprécié que je l'accompagné
il voilà moi c'est ma satisfaction du
jour une satisfaction qu'il souhaite
développer progressivement il se
construit une clientèle il espère
pouvoir toucher un premier salaire
l'année prochaine avec à l'horizon les
clés du bonheur au travail